Carson Palmer courtesy of FedEx and we I
am so excited for his football live
Friday night on NFL Network 88 Eastern
Time
here on the Rich Eisen show hi Ben
Carson I'm doing well how are you well
we've been having a debate here and I'm
wondering from from a an athlete of note
such as yourself we're talking about
fans in a game at a stadium wearing a
jersey of a team that's not playing in
the game and whether that's a code
violation or not Carson what do you
think I'll tell you what you know you
want to know where that is rampant and
that is in London we we went over there
and played against Iran last year and 99
percent of the stadium were wearing
other players jerseys from other teams
and they loved it they think they're
they were watching the Rams Cardinals
game wearing a Brian Urlacher Jersey and
they didn't care they loved it and I
don't have a problem with it
I do if you're in the United States and
you do it so this is a domestic rule
internationally it's like it's a
wonderful thing to look at how the game
has grown and but here domestically
Carson I mean if you're a fan of a team
and you're going to a game and you're
you know your team's not out there you
you you can't wear the jersey of a team
that's that's not actually playing in
the game to that game no no that's a
huge faux pas you can't do that in the
States London it's cool but over here
you can't do that Thank You Carson hold
on a second though
what if let's let me just dive in here
so let's say you're you know when you're
playing with Arizona somebody showed up
to your game wearing a Carson Palmer USC
jersey have absolutely no problem with
that
I also have no problem watching a Miami
Dolphin vs Jacksonville Jaguars game on
TV and seeing a Carson Palmer Jersey
understands I have no right but if it's
Bengals Cardinals and there's a bunch of
Seahawks jerseys in the stands problem
you can't do that you can't do that on
this side of the water you can't do that
major but acceptable your ticket should
be revoked um Carson Palmer and Chris
Brockman blocks that everyone out there
take the L
right here on the Rich Eisen show how
you ben Carson how's life things are
good things are good I'm in New York
City right now doing a bunch of stops at
a bunch of different media outlets um
I'm honored and excited to be the
spokesperson for FedEx this year and the
air and ground awards I was fortunate
enough to win two of those throughout
the years for the final year but I'm I'm
here talking about that that each week
fedex and ground winters which fedex is
donating two thousand dollars for the
air winter and $2,000 for the ground
winter each week you can log on nfl.com
backslash fedex you can vote on twitter
you can vote on facebook and the best
part about it is is that money goes to
the USO and the USO
what they're doing is they're helping
our retired servicemen and servicewomen
we get re-acclimated civilian civilian
life and and get their next career off
and running so it's a great cause the
money's going to a great cause and I'm
honored to represent FedEx do they
double it for when Ryan Fitzpatrick wins
the air award Carson today I hope I hope
they do because that's my guy he's my
vote this week that's my guy
I love watching fitzy play how about him
running over the safety on the goal line
for the touchdown
it's unbelievable Carson it's amazing
how he keeps on showing up and he keeps
on getting opportunities and he keeps on
doing stuff like what we saw last week
in the Superdome it's crazy
magic in a bottle I never know he can
rip off 400 yards passing he can take
off and run on third down and scramble
around he's he's one of my favorite
teammates ever and and I know he's
played on it seems like half the teams
in the NFL and started for half the
teams in the NFL but a great guy and a
ton of fun to watch I can't wait to
watch and play this week Carson Palmer
here on the Rich Eisen show Josh Allen's
getting the start this week Carson and
you obviously are somebody who sat and
watched for an entire year and he's
gotten a sit and watched for an entire
half d what is your stance on how your
career played out and whether it would
have played out the way it did had you
been thrown right in
in Cincinnati well it's it's almost
impossible well to think back and and
have you know and and know I had an
unbelievable opportunity to sit behind
Jon Kitna and watch and learn and and
see him be the quarterback in the leader
and see when he spoke up and said things
in front of the team I learned how to
study and I learn how to take care of
myself but I also learned what it takes
to be a leader at the NFL level so it
was phenomenal for me of course of
course every every guy wants to play and
once the opportunity but it was a great
opportunity for me I was hoping for Josh
and Buffalo he'd have a chance to sit
back and watch for a little bit you know
he hasn't played a ton of football going
from high school to junior college to
Wyoming and and now all of a sudden in
the NFL at a whole different talent
level you know I'm excited to watch him
play I think the sky's the limit for him
you know I just hope everybody's as
patient as they need to be with him
because you saw him last week it's not a
great it's not a great team yet if they
continue to build that team and and he
continues to to get his time and and
their their patient and and putting the
right pieces around him you have a
fixture in your organization for years
because he's gonna be a great talent
well there's a number one overall pick
fresh off winning in Heisman Trophy
who's sitting in Cleveland right now
sitting in the state of Ohio I mean it's
pretty much the same situation as you
without instead it's Browns instead of
the Bengals what do you think Baker
Mayfield is learning right now watching
well I know I know firsthand I mean he's
sitting with with Tyrod Taylor who's an
unbelievable guy and as thorough as a
pro you could find and then Drew Stanton
who had a chance to play their zona who
I also know is a great great prepare he
understands how to break down film he's
helping Baker along I'm sure with that
but for Baker to sit back and watch
those two vets we've both been in the
league for a long time watching them
study watching them prepare and and just
waiting for his opportunity and and
hoping to capitalize on that opportunity
he's in a great situation with some
great is that surround them same thing
with Sam Donald's and Arnold Scott Josh
McCown
who it doesn't get any better than
having Josh McCown to to bounce ideas
off of and ask questions on a Wednesday
and and then ask questions again on
Sunday and in the third quarter and
he'll always give you the right answer
and a straight shot those are those two
guys are in great spots I don't know
Josh Allen's situation per se I just
hope that he's got the right people
around him and and that'll help him
nurture and nurture him into being a
great player well it's the whole thought
you know obviously we we can't know cuz
we're not in the meeting rooms were not
there Carson Palmer I get it but I mean
at least Sam Donald though is getting
the lumps out pick six on his first play
but he bounced back on Monday Night
Football and and and he still has Josh
McCown there as a sounding board you
could see McHale go right up to him and
be right there for him at his worst
possible start barring injury of his
career why wouldn't that be helpful for
Baker Mayfield would Stanton and Tyrod
Taylor to go through it right now well I
think I think the Jets are a better team
and and he has a better chance to go out
there and succeed in win I think in in
Cleveland you got a completely new
system you know not not as many of
probably not as much talent as as he
probably has there so it's you know it's
it's so circumstantial for each guy at
some point we're gonna see Baker
I would think during this year but
having a chance to sit back and watch
and learn and listen and and be a part
of those meetings pre and post game it's
invaluable and I think he's learning a
lot and progressing but we're gonna see
him here at some point a couple more
minutes left with Carson Palmer here on
the Rich Eisen show courtesy of the
FedEx airing ground award and also the
football live coming up on the NFL
Network Friday night at 8:00 eastern
time do you think we see Josh Rosen in
your former stomping grounds this year I
think well at some point you know again
it's kind of similar to what we were
talking about they you know it's a new
system it's it's a new staff it's a new
offense it's a new defense it sort of
completely rebuilt offensive line at
some point I think they'll put Josh in
but you know they're being patient they
need to be patient you have to be
patient you know so so many fan base
is want to flip the table upside down
after week one the NFL is my college in
college if you lose a game or you lose
two games your season's over and you're
not playing for national championship
but in the NFL when you play sixteen
weeks and you can get into the playoffs
at nine and seven and ten and six you
just got to be patient especially with
new coaches new systems new players at a
bunch of positions you've got to be
patient and week one is not indicative
of what's going to happen the rest of
the year you just got to have patience
and let the thing play out I think
you'll see Arizona pick up steam and get
rolling because at the end of the day
there's got some really really really
good players I mean you look at Larry
Fitzgerald and David Johnson on the
offensive side of the ball and then you
go over to defense you look at Patrick
Peterson and Chandler Jones I mean you
have some of the best players in the
game at their respective positions on
that team so patience is gonna be key in
Arizona I think though they'll sneak up
on some people by the end of the year
well I'm looking forward to seeing your
football live Friday night 8 p.m.
Eastern Carson Palmer a football life on
NFL Network thanks in advance for saying
you couldn't have done it out without me
and Susie with Susie covering you in
college and me and the pros that that we
were there for you every step of the way
I appreciate you giving some time to us
who knows where I would be without you
too right I mean that's okay no doubt
it's okay for you to say that though you
too man I'm so excited to see this
football off you deserve it you really
do appreciate thanks for having me rich
you got it it's always good to catch up
always let's catch up again soon Carson
Palmer here on the Rich Eisen show the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience